[Music]
Guinan slim so Quinton slim stars Daniel
Kahlua and Jody Turner Smith they play a
couple they're not really a couple
they're on a date it starts out on their
first day that this movie just gets
going and I appreciate that but they're
on a date it's a bit of an awkward date
then they get pulled over you know how
it's gonna go down it's one of those
cops so we're going 55 no 54 car yeah
and it goes that this guy's on the
warpath clearly a dick cop so out of
self-defense he shoots and kills the cop
and now they're like I guess we're on
the run enter Queen and slim which I
don't think they actually get called
Queen and slim in the movie nor do you
get their names so I guess I'll just
call him him and hurt what else I dug
this movie because this movie gives you
a relatable character I will say a
singular relatable character look he's
just more relatable than her like when
you first meet him he's super relatable
he's nice he's cool he's chill he's laid
back I like him he's a dude you would
hang out with she came across as a bit
of a princess at least when you first
meet her in the movie I felt she was the
more standoffish one as the movie goes
on it does peel back the layers of her
life and you do see what's going on so I
feel like she actually has more
evolution in her character than he does
but talking about when I first met them
but there's an arc between the two and
that's what the movie really is about is
those two is the theme of police
brutality in it yes it is it's the
catalyst that gets it all going also
people's perception of them and I really
like that the difference between how
people see them and how they see
themselves like that because I feel like
that's just the reality in a lot of
things how you see your heroes is not
how your heroes see themselves they're
just they're just people and they're
probably just figuring it out as they go
along so it is about them it's about the
most intense second date ever
I guess we'll call it because if I'm
gauging that first date there wasn't
gonna be a second date look it's like
this no logical human being would
compare this movie to knocked-up and
that's not really what I'm doing but you
know how it knocked up how knocked up
isn't really about pregnancy it's about
two people being thrown together stuck
together because of a situation
otherwise they wouldn't really be
together and they're like well the
situation has thrown us together and we
are linked now so let us press on it's
like
it's not really about oh these two who
killed a cop who was a dick this movie
has an insanely great first act that
first act you like is fighter flight is
somewhere in the second act it kind of
lets up on the pedal and it relaxes
which is kind of a bummer because that
immediate threat you always felt was
right behind them in the first act it
doesn't feel as close anymore and
looking back at it I get that the movie
might be showing them let their guard
down you don't feel the threat and that
makes you relaxed and they're relaxed
and you're supposed to feel that way
because in the third act it does pick
back up but still I still feel like in
that second act it just it loses
momentum a bit there was a scene in the
third act what's the word I hated you're
enjoying something and then something
happened so quickly it just it makes you
just hate it and then you're back into
it again like that
alright the movie has a hold good though
it's kind of like that I just didn't
like the thing that it's during this
scene in fact that entire scene because
the movie is seen through their
perspective their point of view it's
Queen and Slim's eyes they don't have a
lot of time to check the news check the
social media buzz check how the protests
are going I suppose if we had more
insight as to how the world is dealing
with the situation the chatter is online
the scene wouldn't have felt so out of
the blue if that thing that happened and
that entire scene was taken out of the
movie I feel like the movie would be no
different in fact it might be a bit more
focused a bit tighter I can say there is
going to be a cut a super cut online on
YouTube when this movie comes out on
blu-ray it's gonna be a cut of every
time one person wants the other one to
stop the car the other person says no we
shouldn't and then they do anyway
there's a scene in particular she's like
stop I want to pet the horses he's like
I don't think we should she's like I
think we should stop he's like alright
but make it quick she pets the horses
he's like I want to ride the horse and
she's like I don't think we should
here's like come on I'll make it quick
I'm like I but all in all I really dug
this movie it's intense it's actually
thrilling for two out of three acts it's
a movie that has its social message
social message it I don't even know if
that's the word racial inequality cause
and effect perspective actually there's
a lot of message isn't it it's the
catalyst that gets it all going but they
don't just stop there they don't just
have that be the movie because we've
seen that more than a few times how
there's a movie that wants to have a
message and it's like they don't know
how to construct a movie around it so
that's just the only thing the movie has
going for it I didn't feel like that was
the case with Queen and slim this movie
has its message but also great
characters great relatable characters a
scary situation you're gripping your
seat on more than a few occasions
through great intensity good pacing for
most of the movie some intense tone as a
movie it was really well done Alice a
queen and slim was a great time no
alcohol required right so Queen and slim
have you seen it what you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]